L'espace.
Territoires sans fin que l'homme tente
de conquérir depuis plus de 50 ans.
On a encore beaucoup de choses à explorer,
à découvrir. Ce n'est vraiment que le début.
L'histoire de la conquête
spatiale française,
s'est d'abord construite avec
le développement de ses fusées,
des premières fusées-sondes
Véronique à Ariane,
la France s'est réellement illustrée
le 26 novembre 1965 avec Diamant.
Lors de la mise en orbite
du satellite Astérix.
Elle est officiellement
devenue ce jour-là,
la troisième puissance spatiale mondiale.
La conquête de l'espace en France s'est
aussi bâtie sur l'épopée de ces astronautes.
Neuf Français ont déjà dépassé
les frontières de l'atmosphère terrestre,
et le 10ᵉ est en chemin.
La conquête spatiale, c'est de la science,
de la technique,
du rêve, de la philosophie...
Il y a tout dans la conquête spatiale.
L'histoire de l'espace, c'est également
de la haute technologie française,
mise au service de notre quotidien
grâce aux satellites.
Ces 50 ans de conquête spatiale
nous ont fait changer de regard.
Toute cette technologie successive
au service d'un progrès de l'humanité,
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
à véhiculer aujourd'hui.
Près de 7000 satellites ont été
envoyés dans l'espace.
Environ 2500 sont en activité.
Ils ont ouvert la voie
des communications longue distance,
rapprochant les hommes entre eux par delà
toutes les frontières.
Ils permettent de voir
et de savoir en temps réel,
ce qu'il se passe dans le monde entier.
Et la France a révolutionné
la manière d'observer la Terre,
avec ses satellites SPOT.
C'était une première d'avoir
dans les années 80,
un satellite civil qui donnait
des images avec dix mètres de résolution.
Les moyens spatiaux français ont aussi
permis de transformer la compréhension,
des influences des mers sur les grands
bouleversements climatiques,
grâce à TOPEX/Poseidon.
En une dizaine de jours,
la mesure était bien meilleure,
que ce qu'on avait pu accumuler
en 100 ans de données in situ,
par des navires
océanographique ou autre.
Cette vision d'ensemble
que permettent les satellites,
ont convaincu la France de fédérer
des agences spatiales dans le monde,
pour les mettre au service des populations
dans l'organisation de secours,
lors de catastrophes majeures.
Ils sont également une condition
indispensable à la souveraineté de la France.
Pour surveiller, écouter,
organiser la défense du pays,
dans le but de favoriser
la paix et la sécurité de tous.
On ne fait pas du renseignement
pour du renseignement,
mais pour répondre à une question
concrète de nos chefs.
Et les satellites dépassent parfois
les influences de notre terre.
Ils deviennent ainsi des sondes spatiales
qui partent à la rencontre de comètes,
de planètes de notre système solaire,
pour assouvir le besoin de l'homme
de connaître ses origines.
On recherche la vie dans l'univers.
Partout où il y a de l'eau liquide,
il y a probablement de la vie.
L'espace, formidable écrin qui renferme
les énigmes de l'univers,
et que les instruments spatiaux français,
tentent de percer lors de grandes
missions d'exploration internationale.
Comment les satellites servent-ils
au mieux les intérêts de l'homme ?
Quelles leçons nous donnent-ils
sur l'état de la planète ?
Quelles sont les prochaines étapes
de l'exploration spatiale ?
Des satellites,
des sondes,
des instruments de haute technicité.
Partez à la découverte des grandes
réalisations spatiales de la France.
Les Soviétiques sont les premiers à être
parvenus à placer un satellite en orbite,
autour de la Terre.
Le 4 octobre 1957, le célèbre bip bip
de Spoutnik retentit.
Et change à jamais la face du monde.
La course à l'espace
est engagée avec les Etats-Unis,
qui, quelques mois plus tard, réalisent
la même prouesse technologique.
Le 1ᵉʳ février 1958, le premier
satellite artificiel américain,
Explorer 1 est lancé avec succès.
Et ce n'est que 7 ans plus tard
que l'équilibre du bras de fer,
que se livrent les blocs de l'Est
et de l'Ouest, va être légèrement perturbé.
Le 26 novembre 1965,
les yeux du monde entier découvrent
Astérix, le Spoutnik français.
La France lance sa propre fusée,
et place ainsi en orbite
son premier satellite.
Un engin de 42 kilos pour
55 centimètres de diamètre.
La France se hisse au niveau
des exploits soviétiques et américains,
et devient ainsi la troisième
puissance spatiale au monde.
C'est une volonté politique,
c'est aussi une volonté d'image.
L'une des spécialités
d'Isabelle Sourbes-Verger,
porte sur l'occupation
de l'espace autour de la terre,
et la comparaison des différentes
politiques spatiales,
tant dans leur dimension
technologique que politique.
On essaie de démontrer que, à côté des
Etats-Unis, à côté de l'Union soviétique,
des puissances moyennes peuvent
aussi se lancer dans l'exploration,
peuvent aussi être
des puissances de l'avenir,
et des puissances
qui maîtrisent une technologie,
qui a une valeur symbolique
et psychologique forte.
Astérix est un satellite militaire.
Initialement baptisé A-1
pour armée numéro un,
la seule mission de cette
capsule technologique,
était de valider les compétences
de la fusée à satelliser un objet.
À cette époque, le programme des
lanceurs de satellites de la France,
découlait directement
de la mise au point des missiles,
de la force de dissuasion nucléaire.
Après Astérix,
la France enchaîne les succès.
Dix jours plus tard, son premier satellite
scientifique, FR-1 pour France 1,
est lancé par une fusée
américaine cette fois.
Nous sommes le 6 décembre 1965.
Ce satellite de 62 kilos
est placé en orbite.
FR-1 a pour mission d'étudier
la propagation des ondes,
dans les couches hautes de l'atmosphère.
La France est à ce moment
le seul pays d'Europe,
à maîtriser une technologie spatiale.
Et elle se consacre,
comme l'ont tout d'abord fait
les Soviétiques et les Américains,
à faire voler des expériences
au bénéfice de la science.
Deux mois plus tard, nouvelle
réussite 100% française.
Le 17 février 1966,
avec le satellite D1A.
Développé intégralement par
l'Agence spatiale française,
le CNES, D1A et d'abord
surnommé Zébulon,
en référence au personnage animé.
Un ressort permettait en effet
à ce petit engin de 18 kilos 500,
de s'expulser du dernier étage
de la fusée lors de sa mise en orbite.
Mais c'est finalement le nom
de Diapason qui sera retenu.
Le satellite emportait
avec lui un oscillateur,
avec une fréquence qui allait
servir de référence,
comme l'est un diapason pour la musique.
Avec ce satellite, la France initie
une discipline renouvelée grâce au spatial,
la géodésie consacrée
à l'étude de la Terre,
pour la cartographier
avec plus de précision.
On a l'idée qu'il y a quelque
chose de fascinant à découvrir,
qu'il y a quelque chose
d'important à connaître.
On sent bien que le spatial va ouvrir des
champs de recherche totalement insoupçonnés,
et les Français veulent être
présents dans cette conquête.
Ils veulent y participer
avec leurs propres moyens.
La conquête spatiale française relève avant
tout de la volonté politique d'un homme,
qui avait une grande vision pour
la France, le général de Gaulle.
De retour au pouvoir en 1958,
il mesure très vite l'importance
du spatial et notamment,
des communications à distance pour
garantir l'autonomie du pays.
La France ouvre d'ailleurs la voie
en 1962 avec les Etats-Unis.
Pour la première fois, l'espace
va briser toutes les frontières.
Le 11 juillet,
le satellite américain Telstar,
premier satellite
de télécommunication du monde,
va transmettre à la station
de Pleumeur-Bodou, en France,
une émission de télévision émise
depuis l'autre côté de l'Atlantique.
Une première mondiale.
Sachez qu'aujourd'hui, une partie
de cette conférence de presse,
est relayée par le satellite
de télécommunication Telstar,
elle est suivie des deux
côtés de l'Atlantique.
C'est une nouvelle démonstration du monde
extraordinaire dans lequel nous vivons.
Cette retransmission historique
va révolutionner notre rapport au monde.
Désormais, grâce aux satellites
de télécommunications,
chacun pourra suivre en direct
les grands évènements planétaires.
Et la France, qui veut aussi
son propre satellite de télécommunication,
le développe en collaboration avec
l'Allemagne dans les années 60.
Il s'agit du satellite Symphonie.
Symphonie est un engin
de 400 kilos destiné notamment,
à distribuer des programmes
radio et télé,
et à transmettre jusqu'à 600 communications
téléphoniques en simultané.
Ce satellite permettra entre autres,
le 12 janvier 1975,
au président Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
et au chancelier allemand Helmut Schmidt,
d'échanger leurs vœux
par visioconférence.
Monsieur le Chancelier, je voudrais vous dire
qu'il a paru des photos dans la presse française.
où on vous voit en train
de jouer aux échecs.
Et j'espère que nous aurons bientôt
l'occasion de faire une partie ensemble,
peut-être à l'occasion du sommet.
Le satellite Symphonie est opérationnel,
mais les accords passés avec les Etats-Unis,
pour le lancer ne permettent pas
de l'exploiter à titre commercial.
Cette restriction va motiver la France,
à développer avec ses partenaires
européens une nouvelle fusée.
Ce sera Ariane.
Quand la France lance Ariane,
elle attend et c'est son objectif
prioritaire, que l'Europe soit capable,
de lancer toute seule ses propres satellites
et que l'Europe soit indépendante.
Avec Ariane, la France lancera
dans les années 80,
la première génération
de satellites Télécom 1,
qu'elle pourra exploiter,
cette fois, en toute liberté.
Les télécommunications,
grâce aux satellites,
permettent de faire passer
toutes sortes de données.
Des images, du son, du texte.
Ils nous envoient des chaînes
de télévision du monde entier,
nous connectent en direct
aux événements qui marquent la planète.
Les satellites se substituent
aux infrastructures terrestres,
lorsqu'il est besoin d'établir
des connexions Internet,
des liaisons téléphoniques
au milieu de nulle part.
L'espace fait donc sauter toutes les barrières
et les distances n'ont plus d'importance.
Avec seulement 5 ou 6 satellites
de télécommunications,
l'ensemble du globe peut être couvert,
s'ils sont placés
sur leur orbite de prédilection,
à 36000 kilomètres de la Terre,
l'orbite géostationnaire.
Les satellites se déplacent ainsi
au rythme de la rotation de la planète,
comme fixé au-dessus
d'un même point géographique.
Il s'agit de savoir vers où regarder
pour envoyer et recevoir des informations.
Mais les télécommunications ne sont
pas les seules applications possibles,
avec les satellites.
Autre grand domaine, celui
de l'observation de la Terre,
que l'on appelle aussi la télédétection.
Les satellites optiques sont-elles
des appareils photo,
placés à quelques centaines
de kilomètres d'altitude.
Et les images qu'ils
nous offrent de notre planète,
ont métamorphosé notre regard
sur nous-mêmes.
Cette capacité qu'on a eu
de cartographier le monde, finalement,
et de monter des systèmes
d'information géographique,
de faire ce qu'on appelait
à l'époque les spatiaux cartes,
c'est quelque chose
qui a été extrêmement important,
et qui était un petit peu en avance
de phase. On était très fiers quand on avait,
une image spot sur lequel on pouvait
repérer sa maison, son lieu de vacances...
Spot est effectivement l'un
des grands programmes spatiaux,
qui a permis à nouveau à la France,
de s'illustrer avec le premier
satellite de la série.
Spot 1, lancé le 22 février 1986.
Spot, acronyme de Satellite
pour l'observation de la Terre.
Sa mission première est de constituer
une banque d'images inédites jusqu'alors,
pour le suivi de l'évolution
de la surface terrestre.
Spot est une toute nouvelle
génération de satellites.
J'étais fasciné par l'équipe qui
travaillait sur ce satellite qui avait,
beaucoup d'innovations technologiques.
Le premier satellite avait un processeur,
un calculateur numérique,
un ordinateur de bord. Les autres
satellites des générations précédentes,
c'était des calculateurs analogiques. Ce sont
des câbles, des résistances, des condensateurs.
Mais il n'y a pas
un programme, un logiciel,
qui tourne comme
dans nos téléphones portables.
L'outil optique embarqué à bord de Spot 1
lui permettait de photographier la Terre,
avec une qualité d'image
exceptionnelle pour l'époque,
d'une résolution de dix mètres au sol.
Vous avez les pâtés de maisons,
les infrastructures,
vous n'avez pas la voiture,
ni les passages cloutés.
Michel Courtois a un parcours très riche auprès
des agences spatiales françaises et européennes.
Il est considéré comme l'un
des pères du programme Spot.
Spot, c'est le principe de
ce qu'on appelle le push broom,
Vous avez la barette qui est
au foyer de l'instrument,
et la barrette, grâce à l'optique,
avance perpendiculairement
à sa vitesse au sol.
Il enregistrait les images
au fur et à mesure.
Vous faites une couverture systématique
par balayage de cette barrette,
sur un champ de 60 kilomètres.
C'est comme la télé,
c'est ligne par ligne.
Et pour la première fois, un satellite
optique était capable de pointer son objectif,
à un même endroit
de la surface du globe,
sans être nécessairement à sa verticale.
Une originalité technique rendue
possible par un système ingénieux,
de miroirs orientables.
L'outil optique peut ainsi regarder à gauche
et à droite de la trace au sol du satellite,
et couvrir une bande
de 950 kilomètres de large.
On n'avait jamais mis un système
comme ça en place opérationnel,
on a aussi pensé comment mener
des opérations, quelles sont les procédures,
comment est-ce qu'on répartit les rôles,
comment est-ce que la salle
de contrôle intervient ?
C'était une création complète.
Jusqu'avant le lancement, beaucoup
étaient persuadés qu'on n'y arriverait pas,
et ça a marché. Ça s'est passé comme
les simulations le prévoyait.
Le satellite SPOT 1
va prendre durant sa carrière,
près de 2 700 000 photos
de notre planète.
Dès ses premiers mois d'exploitation,
il va fournir les premières images,
de la catastrophe de Tchernobyl
que l'on verra dans la presse internationale.
Spot marque définitivement l'histoire
spatiale de la France.
30 ans après son lancement,
on en est aujourd'hui à Spot 7.
Avec des outils toujours plus performants
pour la cartographie du globe,
la création de modèles
numériques de terrain,
et le suivi de l'environnement notamment.
Les technologies développées pour
Spot ont laissé un digne héritage,
à de nouvelles générations de satellites.
Les missions des satellites
sont extrêmement variées,
et cela va déterminer leur orbite
et les instruments embarqués.
Mais ils fonctionnent tous
sur le même principe.
Pour ne pas retomber sur Terre,
ils doivent aller très vite.
11 000 km/h pour les plus éloignés,
jusqu'à 28 000 km/h
pour les plus proches du globe.
La structure de base
des satellites est identique,
même si leur forme et leur taille peut
varier de celle d'un ballon de basket,
à celle d'un autobus.
Pour Spot 1, par exemple, il est formé
comme n'importe quel satellite,
d'un module de service, une plateforme qui
supporte l'ensemble des instruments de mesure,
que l'on appelle charge utile.
Ici, il s'agit des appareils optiques.
Elle accueille tous les éléments nécessaires
pour le bon fonctionnement du satellite.
Une antenne pour déterminer
son positionnement,
une autre pour lui envoyer des ordres
et pour recevoir ses prises de vue.
Des panneaux solaires pour alimenter
le matériel électrique,
et le carburant pour modifier l'orbite,
et le positionnement du satellite
dans l'espace si cela est nécessaire.
Grâce aux satellites, la France s'est
également démarquée dans une autre discipline,
l'océanographie.
Essentiel aujourd'hui
à la compréhension du climat,
l'un des grands enjeux de notre siècle.
Dans les années 80, la France,
en collaboration avec la NASA,
lance un projet de satellite
scientifique commun,
le satellite TOPEX/Poseidon.
Son objectif est d'étudier
les variations du niveau des mers,
afin de comprendre
la dynamique des océans,
et son influence
sur les évolutions climatiques.
Les données qu'il va fournir sont sans
précédent dans la précision des mesures.
TOPEX/Poseidon est lancé
avec succès le 10 août 1992,
par Ariane 4, sa plate forme emporte radar
et système de localisation comme charge utile.
Je crois que vu de l'Agence
française à l'époque,
l'intérêt d'avoir un logo NASA
sur un lanceur Ariane 4,
était bien supérieur
à la manip scientifique elle-même.
Juliette Lambin travaille
depuis plus de 10 ans,
sur de grands programmes
spatiaux d'océanographie.
Toutes ces données qu'elle maîtrise
sont déterminantes pour établir,
des modèles d'évolution de notre planète.
Une fois lancée, c'est l'altimètre
français Poséidon qui a été le premier,
capable de faire des mesures.
Il a démontré sa capacité à avoir
la même précision que l'altimètre américain.
En une dizaine de jours,
la mesure était bien meilleure,
que ce qu'on avait pu accumuler
en 100 ans de données in-situ,
par des navires océanographique ou autre.
Je trouvais que être capable de mesurer,
au centimètre près la hauteur des vagues,
c'était fascinant.
C'était fascinant de pouvoir
être un géomètre des océans,
parce qu'on savait se placer dans l'espace.
Et ça, la France est numéro un
au monde dans ce domaine.
La surface de l'océan présente
des bosses et des creux,
qui traduisent la circulation océanique.
On peut prendre l'analogie de la météo,
autrefois, dans les cartes météo,
on voyait les cartes
de pressions et de dépressions,
ça nous donnait les vents
qui s'enroulent autour,
des dépressions et des anticyclones.
Dans le cadre de l'océanographie,
les courants marins,
se forment en boucles et tournent
autour des bosses ou des creux.
Quand le satellite mesure
ces bosses ou ces creux,
qui peuvent avoir plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres de dimension,
caractéristique sur quelques dizaines
de centimètres de hauteur,
on a accès à la dynamique de l'océan.
Le satellite TOPEX/Poseidon a permis pour
la première fois à la fin des années 90,
d'observer le phénomène
climatique nommé EL NINO,
le plus fort du siècle.
Ce courant océanique se manifeste par
la propagation d'une bosse d'eau chaude,
qui a atteint cette année là,
20 à 30 cm.
El Nino perturbe l'ensemble du climat
du Pacifique équatorial.
Il peut provoquer
inondations ou sécheresse,
à l'origine d'incendies.
Topex a démontré l'ampleur
du phénomène et aujourd'hui,
les prévisions de El Nino ont
un impact sur le cours des bourses,
des produits agricoles ou de la pêche.
Parce que si on est entré en période
El Nino que la pêche sera mauvaise,
au Pérou par exemple.
Avec le satellite TOPEX/Poseidon, une base
de données sans précédent a pu être constituée.
On sait désormais que le niveau des mers
augmente chaque année de 3 mm en moyenne.
Le suivi des océans permet d'anticiper
les risques liés aux catastrophes climatiques,
de plus en plus nombreuses.
La connaissance des mers ouvre des applications
très opérationnelles pour la navigation,
la programmation de la pêche et même dans
la gestion des pollutions aux hydrocarbures.
Dix ans après la fin
de l'exploitation de TOPEX/Poseidon,
d'autres satellites ont pris le relais
pour fournir plus d'informations,
sur les océans afin
de nous aider à nous préparer,
et à comprendre les évolutions
planétaires de demain.
Après les télécommunications
et l'observation de la terre, des océans,
la navigation est le troisième
grand domaine d'application,
que nous ont ouvert les satellites.
Et c'est probablement l'un des plus
présents dans notre quotidien.
Le très célèbre GPS et certainement
une des plus remarquables utilisations,
des moyens spatiaux sur Terre.
Il y a une constellation de satellites
qui à 20 000 km d'altitude,
qui permet à tout un chacun,
le matin, sur la route,
d'arriver à bon port avec un boitier
qui est grand comme un téléphone.
C'est complètement incroyable !
Les gens y sont habitués.
C'est ça qui est formidable. Mais il y a
des choses qui sont dues uniquement au spatial.
Le système GPS permet de se localiser
dans l'espace mais aussi dans le temps.
On le sait probablement moins,
mais il fournit l'heure exacte
sur laquelle notre société se synchronise.
Nos réseaux internet,
nos réseaux mobiles.
Il sert aussi de référence
dans les gares et les aéroports,
et même pour l'ouverture de la bourse.
Le système GPS est aujourd'hui la norme
en France, mais il est américain.
Et l'Europe travaille actuellement sur son
propre réseau de satellites de navigation,
Galileo, qui devrait dans les prochaines
années supplanter le GPS,
sur le Vieux Continent.
La France n'est pourtant pas en marge
en termes de positionnement par satellite.
Dès les années 70, des ingénieurs
français ont développé,
le très célèbre système Argos.
C'est un système de localisation et de
collecte de données à partir de balises.
Qui peuvent servir
sur des animaux marins.
C'est une source de données,
pour comprendre la faune des océans,
qui est précieuse parce que
ça permet de localiser,
de savoir où ils sont, dans quelle zone
ils vont essayer d'attraper des proies.
Ce système Argos a un impact
très fort sur les recherches,
et les applications en océanographie.
22 000 balises Argos sont aujourd'hui
disséminées sur l'ensemble du globe.
Et délivrent chaque jour plus d'un million
de messages interceptés par les satellites.
Elles sont un magnifique exemple
d'utilisation des moyens spatiaux,
au service de notre planète.
Elles nous fournissent des données essentielles
sur les évolutions de notre monde.
Et ce système est si performant qu'il a
été décliné en balise de détresse,
qui équipe aujourd'hui
avion de ligne, pétroliers,
voiliers du Vendée Globe et même
des véhicules du Paris-Dakar.
En 30 ans, ces balises ont sauvé
la vie de plus de 40 000 personnes.
Les technologies spatiales
sont omniprésentes.
Elles ont transformé la vision
que nous avions de notre monde,
ainsi que notre façon de vivre sur terre.
Mais ces moyens spatiaux prennent tout leur sens
lorsqu'ils sont mis au service de l'humanité,
lors de la gestion de drames mondiaux.
À l'initiative de la France,
15 agences spatiales se sont accordées,
pour mettre leurs moyens en commun.
Près de 60 satellites sont mobilisables,
dans le cadre de la Charte internationale
Espace et catastrophe majeure.
L'intérêt de cette charte,
c'est d'avoir une flotte de satellites.
Guy Duchossois s'est intéressé
à l'étude du climat,
la gestion des ressource naturelles,
ou encore la protection de l'environnement
grâce aux données satellites.
Il est aussi un des acteurs de la charte
Espaces et catastrophes majeurs.
Avec un seul satellite, on risque d'attendre
plusieurs jours entre deux passages,
au dessus de la même zone. Si on a
10 satellites, on a des passages répétés,
toutes les heures.
Ce qui est très important de réaliser,
c'est que des scénarios des procédures,
des mécanismes ont été développés,
pour aller le plus rapidement possible.
Quand il s'agit d'une inondation, on sait
quel type de satellites il faudra utiliser,
et qui possède ces satellites ? Quels sont
les moyens de réception pour ces données ?
Quelles sont les entités qui peuvent traiter
ces données le plus rapidement possible ?
L'idée de la charte fait
suite à l'ouragan Mitch,
qui s'est abattu en 1998
sur l'Amérique centrale,
l'un des plus puissants du XXᵉ siècle.
La France a proposé de mettre à disposition
l'imagerie de ses satellites SPOT.
Ces données optiques, complétées
par les moyens radar de l'Europe,
ont permis de faire une évaluation
précise des dégâts.
L'urgence était de déterminer
la situation sur place,
l'état des routes, des aéroports,
tout ce qui pouvait aider à définir
les priorités d'intervention.
En quinze années d'existence,
la charte a été actionnée,
à près de 450 reprises.
On dirige tous les yeux,
tous les capteurs,
vers un lieu qui nécessite,
d'apporter des éléments d'information
pour mieux gérer la situation.
C'est une formidable aventure
que cette charte,
c'est qu'elle puisse être activée
avec de plus en plus de participants.
C'est une très belle mission.
La rapidité d'intervention des satellites,
leur vue d'ensemble,
leur vision quasi immédiate
de l'étendue de la catastrophe,
permet en effet de fournir
aux secours les informations essentielles,
pour organiser au mieux
leur arrivée sur le terrain.
Les premières heures sont déterminantes
pour retrouver le plus de survivants.
Comme ce fut le cas en 2010 lors
du tremblement de terre d'Haïti.
Juste après cette catastrophe,
il n'y avait aucune information disponible.
On a réussi à détecter les zones
qui avaient été moins endommagées,
où s'étaient réfugiés les populations.
Ça a été extrêmement utile pour
diriger les secours vers ces zones,
que ce soit en termes d'assistance
médicale, médicaments, nourriture,
et c'était fondamental pour
la protection civile française,
qui n'allait pas envoyer
800 ou 900 personnes,
sans savoir s'ils pouvaient
atterrir, sans information...
Parmi les grandes catastrophes
de ces dernières années,
les Français se souviendront longtemps
de la tempête Xynthia,
qui s'est déchaînée en 2010
sur la façade atlantique du pays.
Une catastrophe nationale.
Selon le gouvernement,
il n'a pas fallu 1 h pour qu'en Vendée,
des centaines de maisons,
soient inondées jusqu'au toit.
Ces effets cumulés à une très
forte marée, ont été dévastateurs.
Le bilan est lourd.
Avec 47 morts en France,
et des dégâts estimés
à un milliard et demi d'euros.
Les images satellites
ont permis l'aide aux victimes,
mais ont également fourni
une information précieuse,
pour les organismes d'assurance
ainsi que les bureaux d'études,
en charge de l'aménagement du territoire.
Le satellite permet
d'avoir une information,
à l'échelle synoptique,
c'est à dire à grande échelle,
très rapidement, avec une image
qui fait 100 km sur 100.
10 000 kilomètres carrés, on couvre
une zone très importante.
Si on y va avec des moyens terrestres,
va demander beaucoup plus de temps.
Donc le satellite
est un outil indispensable.
Ce n'est pas le seul bien entendu,
mais c'est un outil important.
Les satellites nous viennent en aide,
mais ils nous protègent également.
Ils ont même permis à la France de prendre
position contre les Etats-Unis,
lors du conflit irakien en 2003.
L'espace est au service
de la défense française.
Il permet de se libérer de toutes
les contraintes géopolitiques,
et d'être présent sur tous les terrains.
D'abord, c'est c'est un outil de puissance
pour la France et l'Europe,
puisque c'est un outil qui nous permet
de faire l'entrée en premier sur le théâtre.
Le colonel Pieuchot-Ravisy est au
service de la défense française,
depuis plus de 25 ans.
Au milieu des années 2000, il a pris la
responsabilité de programme des satellites,
qui œuvre aujourd'hui
pour les armées françaises.
Rapidement, il faut qu'on soit en mesure
de donner des cartes récentes à nos troupes.
Et un des moyens d'obtenir des cartes,
ça va être les photos satellites.
Ensuite, on va de toute façon utiliser
des moyens satellitaires de télécommunication,
de façon à pouvoir leur donner des ordres,
recevoir des comptes rendus,
ou même avoir des contacts directs
avec nos hommes politiques,
pour qu'ils puissent prendre des décisions.
Sans satellites, on n'aurait certainement
pas le statut que nous avons aujourd'hui.
Le général Testé a pour mission de commander
le Centre interarmées de l'espace,
qui élabore la politique spatiale
militaire de la France.
Il a aussi été responsable de la mission sur le
1er satellite d'observation militaire français.
Depuis la fin de la 2e Guerre mondiale,
la France a un siège à l'ONU.
La France occupe une position
qui était souvent,
intermédiaire entre les positions
soviétiques et américaines.
C'est un rôle que beaucoup
de pays dans le monde,
ont été satisfait
de voir joué par la France.
Et dans ce cadre là, il nous faut une
autonomie d'appréciation de situation,
et de décision. Et ce n'est
que les systèmes spatiaux,
qui peuvent nous l'apporter aujourd'hui.
Les premiers systèmes spatiaux militaires
ont été lancés dans les années 80.
Il s'agissait de satellites
de télécommunications,
chargés d'établir des liaisons
protégés et très sécurisés,
pour joindre les bâtiments de
la Marine nationale dans le monde entier,
et notamment les sous-marins nucléaires.
En 30 ans, les moyens se sont
considérablement développés.
Et 1995 marque un tournant
pour la défense française.
Helios, le premier satellite
d'observation entièrement militaire,
Est lancé le 7 juillet par Ariane 4.
Il est utilisé principalement
pour du renseignement.
Hélios doit faire rentrer la France
dans l'histoire.
Durant le deuxième conflit en Irak,
les images qu'il fournit en 2003,
mettent les Etats-Unis en faiblesse,
quant à la présence supposée,
d'armes de destruction massive.
On avait pu dire que les renseignements
américains étaient erronés,
ou on peut aller jusqu'à falsifier
pour impliquer les alliés.
Ce sont ces images Hélios
qui ont convaincu,
Dominique de Villepin, lorsqu'il
a fait son discours à l'ONU,
pour ne pas participer à côté des Américains
à la deuxième guerre en Irak.
Et c'est un vieux pays,
La France, d'un vieux continent comme le mien,
et qui sait tout ce qu'il doit aux combattants
de la liberté venue d'Amérique.
Fidèle à ses valeurs,
il croit en notre capacité,
à construire ensemble un monde meilleur.
Aujourd'hui, même les Américains sont friands
un petit peu de nos analyses divergentes,
parce que ça leur permet de s'ouvrir
à d'autres analyses.
Les décisions qui sont prises sur
les crises ouvertes et majeures,
comme les crises au Sahel,
en Irak, en Ukraine ...
Sont toutes illustrées sur la base de données
qui proviennent de données satellites.
La configuration des satellites
militaires français est telle,
qu'elle permet d'avoir un survol
de chaque parcelle de la Terre,
au moins une fois toutes les 24 h.
Chaque fois que l'armée veut obtenir
des renseignements avec ses satellites,
elle doit lui envoyer
les instructions nécessaires,
pour réaliser sa mission.
Tout se passe depuis le sol.
Prenons l'exemple d'un satellite optique
qui doit réaliser une prise de vue,
sur une zone de conflit
où la France est engagée.
La commande que doit effectuer
le satellite est programmée,
depuis le centre de l'Agence spatiale
française de Toulouse,
à la demande des armées.
Selon l'emplacement du satellite
d'observation à utiliser,
qui orbite en permanence
autour de la Terre,
et pour assurer une intervention rapide,
cette information peut transiter par
différentes stations françaises de programmation,
comme celle des îles Kerguelen.
On donne un ordre satellite :
Aujourd'hui je veux que tu fasses
telle photo, telle photo, telle photo.
Une fois que le satellite a pris
les photos en question,
il va faire une télémesure.
Il va envoyer depuis
l'espace jusqu'au sol,
les données reçues sur un centre
militaire qui se trouveà Creil.
Une fois que ces données sont reçues,
elles sont travaillées de façon à ce que,
l'image soit exploitable.
Le but est de répondre à une question.
On ne fait pas du renseignement
pour du renseignement,
mais pour répondre à une question
concrète de nos chefs.
Si la France est capable
de surveiller d'autres territoires,
n'oublions pas que les autres puissances
spatiales peuvent en faire autant.
La défense française est sur ses gardes.
Pour exemple, Paris est survolée chaque
jour dans le créneau de 11 h à 13 h,
toutes les 17 minutes par un satellite
de recueil de renseignement étrangers.
Mais la raison principale de la surveillance
de l'espace par la défense française,
repose surtout sur la nécessité de préserver
les moyens spatiaux existants.
Des milliers d'objets, des débris,
encombrent pour plusieurs
décennies et plus encore,
les orbites dites basses situées
en dessous des 2000 km d'altitude,
précisément là où se trouvent
la plupart des satellites d'observation.
Il faut à tout prix éviter les collisions.
L'espace est sous très haute surveillance.
En France, nous avons un moyen de l'armée
de l'air qui s'appelle le radar grave,
qui permet de détecter aussi bien
les satellites que les débris.
La France est capable
de surveiller avec ce radar,
près de 3000 objets d'une surface
minimum d'un mètre carré.
Mais il y en a en réalité plusieurs
dizaines de milliers en orbite,
autour de la Terre,
d'une taille bien inférieure.
Le danger est permanent et la quantité de
débris peut très rapidement augmenter,
de manière exponentielle.
A sept kilomètres seconde, le moindre
petit débris de la taille d'un boulon,
peut faire des dégâts considérables
dans une structure satellitaire.
lorsqu'un débris rencontre un autre,
il en crée des centaines.
Ces débris vont rencontrer d'autres
qui sont plus petits, ou plus gros,
et vont créer encore
des milliers de débris.
À partir d'une collision, on peut créer des
centaines de milliers d'objets de toute taille.
Cet encombrement de l'espace généré depuis
les débuts de la conquête spatiale,
des étages de fusée, des satellites en fin
de vie ou des débris issus de collisions,
obligent, chaque année, les autorités
militaires françaises,
à réaliser seize manœuvres d'évitement afin
de préserver leurs satellites opérationnels.
À titre de comparaison,
au début des années 2000,
elles n'ont effectuaient
qu'une seule par an.
Si la conquête spatiale française a démarré,
comme pour les Etats-Unis et la Russie,
dans une course aux armements
pour des besoins militaires,
les réalisations technologiques
ont très tôt été mises,
à la disposition
de la communauté scientifique.
Et c'est d'ailleurs grâce à la science,
que les programmes spatiaux
français se sont développés.
Dès la fin des années 50,
les fusées sondes Véronique, puis plus
tard la famille des fusées Diamant,
ont démontré la puissance spatiale
et scientifique de la France.
Mais les satellites ont pu aller
encore plus haut, encore plus loin,
avec l'avènement des fusées Ariane.
Les satellites deviennent
ainsi des sondes spatiales,
qui honorent de prestigieux
rendez-vous avec les comètes.
Objets célestes des plus mystérieux,
des plus primitifs,
témoins de la naissance
de notre système solaire.
Elles se sont formées il y a 4 milliards
et demi d'années sans jamais avoir évolué.
Et la France avec l'Europe
est à la pointe dans ce domaine.
Dès 1986, la sonde Giotto s'est
approchée de la comète de Halley.
Giotto a été la sonde qui est passée
le plus près de la comète,
et ça a permis d'avoir la première image.
On en avait jamais vu avant.
La carrière de Francis Rocard passe
par de grandes missions d'exploration,
vers la comète de Halley notamment.
On retiendra aussi son implication dans
les programmes martiens et plus récemment,
sur la mission Rosetta.
Il faut absolument ne pas rater
ce retour de la comète de 86.
La Comète reviendra en 2060.
On est passé au plus près à 600 km.
Roger-Maurice Bonnet a mis en œuvre
dans les années 80,
un programme scientifique européen
inédit, Horizon 2000,
qui a défini de grandes missions d'exploration,
qui sont désormais de grands succès.
J'avais développé le télescope
de la caméra qui,
a pris les premières photos
avec une résolution,
une finesse que personne n'avait pu
obtenir à partir du sol auparavant.
Ce que contiennent les comètes,
c'est très intéressant.
Ce sont des molécules organiques,
des molécules qui composent
l'organe des êtres vivants.
Aujourd'hui, on sait qu'on est loin
encore avec ce qui existe sur les comètes,
de faire de l'ADN.
Mais en tout cas, il y a les éléments
qui permettent de le faire.
La mission Giotto a eu un impact
extraordinaire sur la planète.
Plus d'un milliard de personnes ont
suivi cette aventure à la télévision,
et le pape Jean-Paul II avait même
tenu à féliciter les scientifiques,
qu'il avait qualifié de peace makers,
les faiseurs de paix.
Cet engouement fait évidemment
écho à une mission plus récente,
à laquelle la France
a fortement contribué.
Il s'agit de la mission Rosetta
vers une autre comète,
Tchourioumov-Guérassimenko,
plus affectueusement et très rapidement
surnommée Tchouri.
La sonde spatiale a été lancée en 2004.
Après dix ans de voyage
pour rejoindre la Comète,
à 500 millions de km de la Terre,
Rosetta est sortie de son hibernation.
La sonde mère emportée avec elle,
un petit atterrisseur Philae,
destiné à entrer en contact avec la Comète,
pour l'analyser sous tous ses aspects.
C'est une mission avec un atterrisseur
à grande composante française.
Elle a tous les superlatifs.
Elle a dix années de préparation,
dix années de réalisation,
de l'improbable, de l'incroyable
qui devient du possible, du faisable.
Les missions les plus populaires,
celles qui fascinent le public,
sont les missions qui se posent au sol.
Il y a un 2e phénomène avec Rosetta,
c'est qu'on a affaire à une comète.
Or une comète, c'est actif, on le voit,
ça libère des gaz à 2000 km/h.
On mettrait un micro,
ça ferait un bruit d'enfer !
Et en plus la comète est très fragile,
on voit qu'elle est fissurée,
elle va peut être se casser en deux,
il y a un peu de suspens.
C'est remarquable.
Il y avait une énorme pression,
de poser Philae, il fallait trouver un site.
Un objet actif dont on
ne connaissait rien du tout.
Sylvain Lodiot a un parcours
d'ingénieur international.
Il a notamment opéré sur des programmes
de satellites d'observation de la Terre.
Sur le programme Rosetta,
il supervise les opérations de vol.
Il fallait comprendre comment
naviguer autour de la comète,
Sa force de gravité, son activité.
Comment ça aller perturber Rosetta.
C'est facile de reconstituer
par où on est passé, mais prédire,
comment le dégazage va influencer la trajectoire
de Rosetta, c'est quelque chose d'impossible.
Il a fallu graduellement s'approcher
de plus en plus vers la comète,
pour comprendre un peu tous
ces phénomènes et en parallèle,
trouver un site d'atterrissage.
Le côté risqué de l'atterrissage,
le côté acrobatique,
c'est dans l'histoire du spatial,
relativement sans précédent.
La manœuvre d'atterrissage
en novembre 2014 a duré 7 h.
Philae a chuté à la vitesse
d'un mètre par seconde.
Équipé d'un instrument radar français
pour sonder le noyau de la comète,
et en déterminer la composition.
C'est là toute la mission de Philae
qui va tenter de nous en dire plus,
sur la formation de la terre
et du système solaire.
Est-ce que l'intérieur
est très homogène ?
On pourrait dire que les comètes
se sont formées plutôt calmement,
par des petits grains qui sont venus
se coller sur un gros grain qui a grossi.
Si maintenant à l'intérieur on voit
que c'est formé de gros blocs,
on dira oui, mais c'était
un moment très violent.
Ça s'est recassé et tous ces gros
blocs se sont agglomérés à nouveau.
Donc la formation du système solaire
est beaucoup plus dynamique,
et beaucoup plus violente,
si on trouve ces gros blocs
à l'intérieur de la comète.
J'ai eu le grand plaisir d'accueillir
à la Cité des Sciences,
plus de 3000 personnes qui sont venus
assister à l'atterrissage de Philae,
et à attendre les premières images,
transmises et on a tous
retrouvé son âme d'enfant.
Et une fierté nationale, bien sûr,
parce que des équipes
avaient mis au point,
une aventure technique
absolument extraordinaire.
Et le spatial, ça apporte ça.
Les gens, quand ils ont suivi la mission,
disaient "On" !
C'est-à-dire qu'ils s'étaient
identifiés en tant que personne,
à un objet automatique.
La mission Rosetta, au même titre que
d'autres grands projets d'exploration,
de l'univers, s'inscrit dans le cadre
du vaste projet Horizon 2000,
lancé dans les années 80.
Il était destiné à élever l'Europe au niveau
scientifique des puissances américaines,
et soviétiques.
De nombreuses missions
d'exploration sans précédent,
ont ainsi permis à la France de s'illustrer
dans le cadre de collaboration internationale.
XMM-Newton et les Planck.
Ces missions, déjà entrer dans l'histoire,
scrutent l'univers toujours plus loin,
pour tenter d'en comprendre ces mystères.
Ou encore la mission Cluster.
Avec 4 satellites européens, chargés d'étudier
les interactions du Soleil avec la Terre.
Et même si la mission brille
aujourd'hui par son succès,
elle a pourtant failli ne jamais aboutir.
Les satellites européens
ont d'abord été désintégrés,
lors du tout premier lancement d'Ariane 5.
Le 4 juin 1996, la fusée explose.
Cette mission a été lancée mais n'est
resté dans l'espace que 37 secondes.
Ariane 5 à décider qu'il ne comprenait
pas les ordres qu'on lui envoyait,
il a décidé de retourner
au sol de façon prématurée,
et on a perdu les 4 satellites Cluster.
Il y avait 4 satellites à bord.
Quelques minutes après, je suis allé voir
les scientifiques qui étaient dans un hangar,
à côté de la base de lancement,
et tout le monde était en larmes.
Ils avaient perdu,
presque douze ans de leur vie
scientifique dans cet échec.
Mais la persévérance des scientifiques
et des ingénieurs,
a permis de remonter la mission Cluster
en seulement quatre années.
La France est un acteur majeur de très
nombreuses missions d'exploration de l'espace.
et la longue liste d'instruments scientifiques
réalisés par des ingénieurs français,
ne fait que souligner
l'importance de son apport.
Ces missions permettent la découverte
d'un monde sans limite,
qui nous offrira certainement
un jour les réponses fondamentales,
à la compréhension
de la formation de la terre,
du soleil, des galaxies.
Je crois que ce qui conditionne,
les missions les plus fascinantes,
qui finalement se réalisent, c'est
l'imaginaire et le rêve qui vont ensemble.
Quand je vois ces sondes interplanétaires,
je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de me dire si j'étais à bord,
qu'est-ce que je ressentirais ?
Quelle fierté ! On a réussi.
Regardez, je suis là, je suis vivant,
Je suis en train de creuser !
C'est ce que fait un robot.
Mais le robot, c'est une machine.
Et la fierté qui nous renvoie,
c'est celle des ingénieurs
qui ont mis leur intelligence dedans.
Mais ce qui anime peut être le plus
la communauté scientifique internationale,
dans l'exploration
de l'espace est probablement,
d'envisager la question
de la vie extraterrestre.
Nos rendez-vous interplanétaires réalisés
grâce à nos sondes spatiales,
sont souvent destinés
à répondre à cette question :
La vie existe t-elle
ailleurs que sur Terre ?
Ou du moins d'autres planètes auraient-elles
pu réunir les conditions nécessaires,
à l'apparition de la vie et faire que
notre monde ne soit plus une exception ?
On recherche la vie dans l'univers
sous toutes ses formes,
et cela se traduit
par l'exploration de Mars,
où on cherche à savoir
si la vie est apparue.
Même si des optimistes se disent il y a peut-être
de la vie encore sur Mars dans le sous-sol,
c'est très polémique et on a
aucune preuve aujourd'hui,
et on aura beaucoup de mal
à avoir ce type de preuve.
C'est l'objectif central.
Et Mars est devenu et restera sans doute encore
longtemps l'objet de toutes les convoitises.
Les expéditions vers la planète
rouge sont nombreuses.
Après un raté avec les Russes
sur la mission mars 96,
la France démarre réellement
cette exploration en 2003,
avec la Mission européenne
Mars Express.
Cette mission était intéressante
parce qu'elle permettait d'analyser,
ce qui n'avait pas été fait auparavant,
le sol, l'atmosphère, l'interaction
de Mars avec le vent solaire.
Pour moi, ce fut un très grand succès.
Sa plus grande découverte de la décennie
concernant cette planète,
a été faite sur la mission Mars Express,
par un instrument français qu'on appelle Oméga,
qui est un spectromètre infrarouge,
qui mesure la vibration des molécules,
la minéralogie du sol.
Cet instrument a découvert des argiles
à la surface de Mars,
et les argiles sont la signature que
ces minéraux issus de roches volcaniques,
se sont fabriqué en présence d'eau
liquide dans un milieu plutôt neutre,
et donc très propice
à l'émergence de la vie.
Et cette présence d'eau liquide sur
Mars a été confirmée en septembre 2015,
par la NASA grâce aux observations réalisées
par la sonde Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter.
Des chercheurs français et américains ont
découvert qu'un mélange d'eau et de sel,
circulait sur certains reliefs
de la planète en fonction des saisons.
Et les sites argileux
plus faciles d'accès,
sont encore aujourd'hui les terrains
explorés par curiosité,
ce robot martien a passionné
les foules à l'été 2012,
et la France a encore une fois joué
un rôle majeur en fournissant,
les outils les plus importants
de la mission d'une technologie inédite.
L'atterrissage de Curiosity restera
dans toutes les mémoires.
C'est très rapide, tout est automatique,
vous ne pouvez rien faire.
C'est ce que les Américains appellent
"7 minutes de terreur."
C'est une voiture donc on ne peut pas la poser
avec les ballons, comme les robots précédents,
il a fallu la poser avec un système
très ingénieux de grue,
sustenter par ses propres moteurs fusées,
un câble qui descend le roveur,
après il s'éjecte séparément.
C'est fascinant !
L'exploration de Mars va probablement
durer encore quelques décennies,
à la recherche d'une quelconque
forme du vivant.
Ou de conditions passées qui
auraient pu accueillir la vie.
Cette exploration s'organise
en trois phases clés.
Elle est "follow the water",
d'abord déterminer l'histoire de l'eau.
Cette question est maintenant
à peu près réglée.
La deuxième étape, c'est celle d'en
ce moment même, c'est Follow the carbone,
rechercher des molécules organiques
dans le sol de Mars et Curiosity,
sur lequel la France
joue un rôle important,
puisque nous avons 2 instruments
franco-américains,
le laser qui tire et la grosse
usine à gaz qui s'appelle Sam,
qui fait près de 40 kilos,
qui est en partie française,
et qui est l'instrument phare qui
mesure ces molécules de carbone.
Follow the carbone, c'est en ce moment.
L'étape suivante c'est follow the life,
rechercher des traces de vie, des bio
signatures, des preuves que la vie existait,
encore une fois
dans un passé très lointain.
Le Graal de l'exploration
de Mars pour conclure,
c'est de ramener
des échantillons sur Terre.
Cette mission n'a toujours pas
eu lieu et pourtant elle aura lieu,
j'en suis convaincu,
dans les 10 ans qui viennent.
Et ça sera le seul moyen de prouver,
que la vie existait sur Mars.
Inconcevable d'imaginer aujourd'hui
un monde sans espace,
un monde sans communication,
sans défense,
et surtout sans conscience
de l'état de santé de notre planète.
Le développement des technologies spatiales
est aussi la clé de l'exploration de l'univers.
Les scientifiques profitent des outils spatiaux
sans jamais quitter le sol terrestre.
L'enjeu est d'en savoir toujours
plus sur nos origines,
celle de la vie, celle de la terre,
de notre système solaire
et sur l'origine même de l'univers.
Des premières fusées ou sondes d'exploration.
De Jean-Loup Chrétien à Thomas Pesquet.
La France,
à travers sa classe scientifique,
technique et industrielle,
à travers tous ses moyens technologiques,
façonne depuis 50 ans
le quotidien de l'homme d'aujourd'hui
et de celui de demain,
en le faisant réfléchir toujours plus
sur la petite place qu'il occupe sur Terre,
et peut-être mieux comprendre celle
que lui réserve l'infini de l'univers.
L'histoire de la conquête
spatiale continue.